et
[Musique]
avec la pilule du professeur shadow kyo
le ministre de la population a pondu des
shadoks en pièces détachées shadow qu à
une idée pour les rafistoler c'est
excessivement simple suivez mon
raisonnement
partons de ma cellule sortie de cette
machine et par le truchement de notre
dévoué ministre j'obtiens des shadoks on
pièces détachées par conséquent en
réinjectons les mauvais shadoks côté
pilule et en actionnant à l'envers il
doit sortir de notre processus les
shadoks août
on va essayer et alors que sort-il de
l'autre côté monsieur le professeur
sortie devinez quoi
une pilule mais ne nous affolons pas ne
nous affolons pas là nous avons
plusieurs solutions première solution
nous ré administrons la pilule aux
ministres nous injectons le coup et nous
obtenons voyons voyons un oeuf et un
ministre aidons le à une autre pilule
mauvaise solution
deuxième solution injectons l'oeuf par
là
les shadoks en morceaux par là nous
avons une pilule est un ministre en a
déjà un très mauvaise solution
troisième solution la bonne suivez-moi
bien nous coupons la piste le morceau
nous la mettons dans les autres là les
impopulaires
nous injectons nous agitons et nous
avons encore une pilule et et c'est tout
eh bien c'est raté
et non ce n'était pas tout monsieur le
professeur et non ce n'était pas tout
car voilà que la machine
c'était à marcher voilà qui sait des
pâtes et qu'elle courait après les
pièces détachées et qu'elle laissa
valais voilà qu elle grossissait
qu'elles grossissent est qu elle
grossissait ont un énorme talent compte
un shadow contraire infernal déchaîné
affamés qui tout à l'heure d'aller
manger la dernière-heure guichard
occassionnés ils vont mourir à cette
fois oui c'est bien lapin et tout ça à
cause d'une pilule la pilule des
professeurs mais il y à une quatrième
solution lab dont votre main la pilule
professeur la pilule dite l'achat d'or
que la chine avait englouti sa pilule
comme c'était justement une pilule a
coupé les shadoks en morceaux j'adore
ces coups là en un énorme tas de
détritus s'était finie et il peut encore
sauver cette fois là il s'en passait
quand même de drôles de choses sur la
lune
[Musique]